what do you consider to be the perfect
screenplay and why whether it's your own
work you know this is first time stay
ready for you although you're getting a
book and journalists the two of you
perfect screen but whether it's someone
else's or even a page out of your own
that you're working on I think for me
because this was my first screenplay one
of the things that I wanted to do was
read every screenplay I could get my
little hands on and one of the actually
there's three that I've really kind of
gravitated to dallas buyers club which i
still have yet to see but i have read it
and i've read it about four times I
think it's a marvelous screenplay and
I'm almost afraid to watch it I know it
did well and I just I it was like a
novelty it read almost like a novel and
sometimes I'm afraid to like look at you
know cuz it doesn't match my my vision I
mean and I know it did well if he oscars
and it was very inspiring for me because
that was a project that took about 20
years to make but it's just so well
structured it moves so beautifully it's
so visual in its construct I felt the
same way about bridesmaids and then I
went back in red guess who's coming to
dinner the the original screenplay for
guess who's coming to dinner and that
screenplay just the opening is tons of
fun it's just I think there's a line in
there where it says you know this this
black man and this white girl kiss in
the taxicab and watch the audience go
crazy it was like they were commenting
you know this film was done in 1967 it
was written in 1967 before the virginia
VS loving a ruling came down that
allowed interracial couples to marry in
the united states and so this was still
a big deal at the time and so just
reading that first bit of narrative was
was it was hilarious and it's
it's just really well done for I mean
for me there's just so many the first
script I think I ever read was Alexander
Payne's election and he's somebody who
has a lot of voice in his in his scripts
he'll be kind of witty or you know you
and a lot of times he's adapting I think
almost always he's adapting from a book
and so maybe some of that is is coming
from that but I mean I remember thinking
oh you have to have style in the way
that that you're expressing something
and that the tone of your movie can be
reflected in the voice of your
screenplay I mean I love children of men
I go back to that a lot eternal sunshine
of the spotless mind as a movie and i
think i have read that this I have a
picture in my in my head of the
screenplay and I'm I'd have to think a
little harder about how that translates
what did I just I'm not halfway through
a beautiful mind right now and that does
really interesting things too so I don't
know about the perfect screenplay but
there's a lot of great movies out there
that had as screenplays great blueprints
on their own and in their actualization
because I know when I I went back to
what like my one of my favorite films of
all times is broadcast news I love that
film and I went back and read the
screenplay and the screenplay is very
different is different in a lot of ways
than what was actually shot so it gave
me a different and maybe that's why I
don't want to see Dallas writers are
like what if they took this out oh no
what if that's not in there so there
were things in the broadcast news script
that weren't in the film and or things
that were dialogue that was changed and
so it was really interesting because I
know that screenplay I mean I know that
film so well to then go back and watch
the screen to
read the screenplay and see how
different it was it was it was actually
very interesting and revealing but now
it's just like ho dog why did I wasn't
that I wasn't that in the movie so so
yeah so that's yeah that's I think it's
I'm actually I'm teaching a class at one
of the community colleges this fall and
it's going to be my first experience
teaching a screenwriting class and we're
going to be working with short films but
the book that I've selected specifically
because they have the scripts for the
short films in the book but they are not
transcriptions of the movies that got
made because i think it's it's so
important to realize that whatever it is
that you're making is only a part of the
whole that like that as much as this is
a collaborative process that when we get
to the next stage it's going to be
another collaborative process and then
it's going to become something else so i
think it is interesting and sometimes
you do look back and like something got
lost and then sometimes it just
transcends what was there so
you